We are starting the straighten
up and fly right maneuver,
where the spacecraft will jettison the
entry balance masses in preparation for
parachute deploy and to roll over to give
the radar a better look at the ground.
[inaudible] indicates chute
deploy. The navigation
has confirmed that the
parachute has deployed and
we are seeing significant deceleration in
the velocity. Our current velocity is 450
meters per second at an altitude of about
12 kilometers from the surface of Mars.
Heat shield sep. Perseverance has now slowed
to subsonic speeds and the heat shield has been
separated. This allows both the radar and the
cameras to get their first look at the surface.
Current velocity is 145 meters per
second and an altitude of about
10 kilometers - nine and a half
kilometers above the surface.
Nav filter converge lastly solution 3.3 meters
per second, altitude 7.4 kilometers. Nav has
radar lock on the ground. Current velocity is
about 100 meters per second, 6.6 kilometers off
the surface of Mars.
Perseverance is continuing to
descend on the parachute.
We are coming up on the
initialization of terrain relative navigation
and subsequently the priming of the landing
engines. Our current velocity is about 90 meters
per second at an altitude of 4.2 kilometers.
LVS valid. We have confirmation that the lander
vision system has produced a valid solution
and part of terrain relative navigation. Priming
pba is nominal. We have
priming of the landing engines.
Back shell sep. Current velocity is 83 meters
per second at about 2.6 kilometers from the
surface of Mars. We have confirmation
that the back shell has separated.
We are currently performing the divert maneuver.
Current velocity is about 75 meters per second
at an altitude of about a kilometer off
the surface of Mars. TRN safety bravo.
We have completed our terrain relative
navigation. Current speed is about 30
meters per second, altitude of about
300 meters off the surface of Mars.
We have started our constant
velocity accordion which means we are
conducting the skycrane - about
to conduct the skycrane maneuver.
Skycrane maneuver has started.
About 20 meters off the surface,
we're getting signals from MRO.
Tango delta. Touchdown confirmed.
Perseverance safely on the surface of Mars,
ready to begin seeking the signs of past life.